[Music]
good morning everybody today we are
going on a venture date yesterday yeah
event today so anyways today we're going
to do something very new it's not the
first time we've ever done it but it's
our second time and we're going to be
floating today what we're going to be
going into it's called a sensory
deprivation paint pretty much you get
into this tank there is going to be no
sound no light you're going to be
loading in this water that they put I
don't know how many tons of salt so you
could be like really buoyant even more
buoyant than the Dead Sea they say we
really wanted to do a video for you guys
so you guys can see our experience and
see if you guys want to come down and
try it at just floats it's here in
Pasadena we'll put the address right
here in the screen there you guys can
you guys can come and check it out for
yourself
we'll also be having a discount code in
the description because we are
collaborating was just float so you
really wanted to bring this experience
to your guys's attention because it's
really awesome it's really helpful for
people that are getting over certain
trauma like PTSD if you suffer from
anxiety or things like that I like
coming into these tanks that really
removing yourself from the world it does
a world of a difference go check it out
let's do it
the first time I came I kept freaking
out for some reason I kept trying to
convince myself I was floating in space
not a cool warning space it then all of
a sudden my mind would pick tricks on me
and say there's an alien behind you and
I'm like SSS was freaking out so I
couldn't do it I ended up having to turn
on the lights open the door I slowed it
closes over for me my first experience
wasn't the best but that's why I'm back
again because I really want to conquer
whatever fear came out of me that first
time I hear once we get over that hump
like over the initial process of
floating and that's when you really get
to experience glit and like you just
like floating you're just really free
and I wanted to be able to experience
that that's where we came back my first
time here I had the same like
hyperventilating experience for about
five minutes but afterwards though they
look to kind of calm down and relax I
think I probably laid there for maybe 10
minutes more before I passed out I've
taken like mindfulness meditation
classes I'm really into meditating on
that kind of stuff now something like
this like floating is very conducive for
meditation and stuff like that you hear
your breath you can hear your heartbeat
and so it's just a great platform for
internalizing everything and relieving
yourself of outside stresses
I'm just wishing
[Music]
we have four cabins up here for another
seven fact which is the roads are
slippery oh really
we have you guys in the room 10 11 so
we're going to be walking all the way
here all your food supplies are in that
box there including everything from
petroleum jelly percussion scratches to
the full captivate so super excited
about this
so today's dedicated mind into this
reset day and every a try and just
forget about JK bit about applause
forget about how to do even though we're
making this vlog experience look like
these really helped me to kind of reset
anyway it's time to get naked and time
to start so close is my around both in
slowly happens people please be a TA
accessible flow tank in the world to
almost
something licensures and especially
better PTSD yeah okay all right
salt ocean this is perfect for my period
I got really close your folks okay thank
you so much welcome to enjoy your
clutter thank you so for me for my first
time voting Oh fine just fine except for
the fact that I had I had to flip like
this like I would put both of my arms I
was holding my head like this woman in
the center of her back felt really tight
so I'm going to be doing and I know that
the first to visit the happy little
things they should put over your head
your head slowly
just relax not reliant so I'm going to
be using different types as well first
time I reach in a shower first one
cheers to shower
it requires dirt and everything clean
you get in the tank and then you start a
little papa
and what's really cool about this place
is that they actually filter out the
water between each person that comes in
four times which is really comforting to
know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like control you just in case
yes hot water in your patron your eyes
you have a little bit fresh water to a
cleanser face with right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
people remind water operatic you're on
I don't think about it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh also created every even so unaffected
by gravity from past our bar to my money
turn back on chilly night coloring with
you outside left light on this tub the
whole time complete darkness until 3:00
for me plus I can get really night owl
I literally love clean the lover lovers
kind of giving you a sign that pay your
tens up time to take a shower
tend to go back into the real world
somebody shout cool straining heads
oversold and they have like a whole
system factor that
I'm queen of the water how they do it
opening their water to filter out coming
out of the think you really feel default
[Music]
all right I'm dressed and I'm ready to
join the rest of the world not let's go
to a disco all showered and dressed
ready to go it's pretty cool that they
have to thank you to tell me have any
cut or these really cool earplugs
they were pretty cool to cover like
Nicole better you're here and having
drop thank you this time I knew try the
air plus I had to water go in my hair
until they say like you really want to
be treating it all the salt water out
because I want to dry your hands which
is all crystal so that I made sure to do
then things
that's a cosas really dry up everything
missing here and they have these
cutaneous and makeup wipe and a bottle
of water complimentary bottle of water
which I will be taking every Thursday
night all done
see look cases
hello I was it was so cool I had way
better experience this time my mind was
still really busy and I kept trying to
like focus on the breathing and my
common rage relax let go
so my mind kept they was still really
busy as soon as the entire room got dark
like pitch black I open my eyes and it's
just like that is dark like I can see
anything I felt like I went blind so I
don't think I lasted more than a minute
in complete darkness and they
immediately turn the lights back on like
I'm sorry you can't do this like baby
says okay you keep this I get thinking
about the wedding to my own because
let's just well don't think about it
right not world well I was bring away
here I was trying my hardest to not
think about it so it was a constant
battle but I did have a much less
experience this time because I wasn't
worried about being like conscious
phobic because everything was really
open and really soothing I had a really
nice time I didn't know like and I bring
two different miralax
what goes better look easy they okay
keep it a little bit with the beard oh
wait does he have a beard yeah he does
you want to draw something here
I'm not much of a artist I look a lot on
I think it's a lot impairing thing
although something that's how I feel if
it feels it yeah alright so here at just
load they have this room after your
float to come here and sit down and just
relax and they have this book and you
can write into and kind of share your
thoughts and what you got out of your
float and it's really cool to kind of
scroll through some of these scribbling
left by other people what they thought
of it even though everyone has a
different way of drawing or writing and
they you know to do different things but
if you go through all of them they all
pretty much encompass the same thing in
a way like this enlightenment that's
pretty cool that everyone kind of gets
the same effects coming out of floating
it's very Universal this one wow that's
really good yeah we have to lie to
people cause plenty more blank pages you
want to definitely awesome I'm gonna
adult color name you can draw some TV
I've actually been wanting again adult
coloring book so suiting when I was a
kid I should tell my friends I'm gonna
grow up to be a color because I love
color and colorist that's what I call
yeah I wanted I wanted to just color
things and for my job as a career that's
awesome I kind of thought you had a kid
exactly this good it's gonna grow up to
be an artist of any kind no okay I'm
going to draw what I saw my head in the
darkness while I was floating I did see
something actually you know what looks
like this sonar you drew it from yeah oh
you're in the dark and like there's like
CCD start seeing like shapes and stuff
that's kind of like what I started
seeing things like that
all right so I'm all done coloring this
in all bein on the camera I look like
I'm really color it all in but trust me
every single inch of this thing has
colors just that these color pencils
learned that pigment but yeah well I was
doing this what were you up to
I was making my drawing the fish flour I
call it oh so pretty
you have like the petals and then each
fish is like part of the flower
yeah and I chicken scratch signature
they're flower fish fish power up your
sushi restaurant fish flower or it could
be something else like dirty flower I
have no idea
are you talking about I don't know so
we're all finished up here that coloring
/ drawing session is really relaxing
make sure to check out the description
guys we put in a code for you guys to
come down here and experience it all for
yourself but yes privations I go let's
redecorate again this point what the
faucet variations
sensory deprivation is that's your
decoration yes
[Music]